where most of the pocket dimensions of
the universe began to take shape under
the control of their respective rulers
the dimension of Asgard was coming into
existence according to Norse mythology
Asgard originated as a landmass split
into two sections with the North
existing as a frozen barren wasteland
and the south existing as a fiery barren
wasteland with the two sections having
12 rivers that met in the middle over
time
the frozen rivers of the north began to
overtake the south giving way to the
birth of a mere as the first frost giant
finding himself exposed to the warmer
air of the south Emir began to shrink in
size
eventually melting away entirely and
revealing a man and a woman following
this above line appear through unknown
means and provided nourishment to the
man and woman through its utters finding
a self sustenance by licking away at the
ice following this pattern the bovine
eventually looked away to block of ice
which revealed itself to be burry who in
turn spawned boar the founder of Asgard
and the father of cool V Lee V and Odin
where the realm of Asgard would evolve
to see Odin rising to power and mating
with Gaia to produce Thor during this
time a race known as the saurians
traveled the spaceways seeding life
throughout various planets spawning the
Kree the scrolls and humanity who in
turn began to evolve within the confines
of their own planets and forming their
own kingdoms following this around 1
million years prior to the current day
the Celestials continued their journey
of exploration across the cosmos
eventually stumbling upon earth viewing
the planet as a host for celestial egg
the Celestials themselves planted their
egg within the earth and began
experimenting on a group of primitive
men known as the Wanderers who were
gathered together by Gaia to the
experiments of the Celestials three
sects were formed the deviants the
Eternals and humans
receiving their modifications from zero
on the tester the deviance represented
instability with their race experiencing
unchecked mutations leading to each saw
spring experiencing a half-life of the
previous generation reducing the overall
length of the deviance expected
existence from the czar the calculator
Camie terminals beams who are perceived
to be perfect in terms of evolutionary
maturity and possess the power to tap
into and manipulate cosmic energies
finally Oh negative probe er created a
latent gene within the remaining humans
allowing for limitless expansion of
genetic potential sending the races
forward into earth where the three
groups were modified to serve as
protectors of the celestial egg instead
each race gave in to their natural state
the Eternals took to the skies building
kingdoms for themselves with no concern
for the goings-on of humanity or the
deviants at the same time humanity found
itself enslaved by the Debian's who used
humans to build their various structures
and cities lasting until 16,000 BC when
the Celestials appeared on earth a
second time the Rachel is attacked by
the deviants who view the Celestials as
a threat to the dominion over earth
devastating the deviance numbers and
sending the survivors underground the
Eternals abandoned the planet taking up
residence on the Saturn moon Titan as
well as exploring the rest of the cosmos
leaving the landscape of Earth open
humanity began to spread and expand
their sphere of influence to the
furthest corners of the world creating
empires and kingdoms with each
worshipping their own deities during
this time and while in the midst of a
war with their rival race the scrolls
the Cree race observe the actions of the
Celestials and look to expand their own
sphere of influence by modifying the
genes of humanity allowing them to take
on forms identical to other races which
in turn would allow the Cree to subvert
those races from within paving the way
for them to conquer those planets
kidnapping various humans and modifying
their genes the Cree ruler known as the
supreme intelligence foresaw the end of
their race at the hands of their
experiments and in turn
order all experiments to be cleansed and
all knowledge or existence to be
stripped from Cree records however in
its rush to judgment the supreme
intelligence failed to take notice of
five experiments in the form of
primitive man
the Badoon the Dyer race the chameleons
and the Centurions where each of these
groups continued on unaware of their
lineage within the confines of earth the
Cree experiments began to form their own
order society under the theme of a
monarchy to descend in at some point in
their past a geneticist named randbek
discovered Terrigen crystals and began
to synthesize the process of
terrigenesis allowing the human
experiments to undergo exposure to the
myths which in turn transmogrified the
humans and unrecognizable forms but
sometimes possessing extraordinary
abilities christening themselves in
humans the race kept itself isolated
within the sacred city of Attilan and
away from the goings-on of the deviants
and the rest of humanity where the
Inhumans remain isolated because of the
actions of the Celestials and pushing
the deviance to near extinction
technology was lost to humanity for
millennia sending the race into a near
feral state referred to as a Hyborian
age this time period not only saw the
introduction of Conan the Barbarian in
red Sonia but also saw the rise of the
first mutant as well as direct
interaction with the second generation
of gods while almost nothing is known of
Celine's past what we do know is that
because Selene maintains her longevity
by absorbing life energies through
physical touch during the time of her
birth she unintentionally killed her
mother viewing Selene as a goddess
destined to rule the world the tribal
leaders of the clan ordered Celine's
people to sacrifice their lives so they
may live forever as part of her where
Selene would spend the next several
thousand years wandering the world her
journeys allowed her to witness the rise
of the second generation of gods coming
in the form of Norse Greek Roman and
other cultural mythologies while these
gods had existed for countless years
this time period saw their first
interactions with society at large
because of this the cultures of the
world gave way to worship to Oh
Zuse vishna Yahweh and Amin rah among
others while this remained the standard
practice of humanity's relationship with
the second generation of gods the world
was met with the arrival of its second
mutant and 5000 BC but I enjoy the
people I work with because I work with
writers with artists now with directors
producers and I'm always working in an
atmosphere where we're trying to think
of what can we do now